Look at when she sees me go all the way
around.
I don't enjoy it, bro. We're heated.
Take the training. But I pick my
hardships. This is You see these
brothers always pick on sisters. Look at
these guys.
>> I want to invite you to add something
powerful to your jar list.
>> We're on a mission
>> to teach tens of thousands of people
around the world
>> how to pray salah properly.
>> Just imagine this. You help someone
learn with how to pray,
>> how to recite surah fat,
>> every
prayer for the rest of their lives,
>> you share in a reward.
>> When they teach their children
>> and their children's children,
>> the reward continues for you. For just
£100,
>> you can help teach 20 to 60 people like
you. Learn salah. Donate today and earn
rewards that never stop.
>> Brother sisters, the brothers Balhammed
and came all the way from Manchester.
Alhamdulillah. They connected us with
the prisons which we supply the mats to.
Alhamdulillah. We was wanting them to
come to our studio. They finally came
after months. So we did a discussion
with Muhammad about his journey to Islam
practicing again gang lifestyle and the
burials that he does etc. And the
stories that the past and you know what
we've done the da but what about the
mind and the body the soul is in check.
So the mind and the body sisters the
mind we're going to go to the ice bath
in if you guys are ready for it 60° and
now we're going to do a circuit
inshallah and then do a bit of
calisthenics and see how that goes and
they open the new place in the new
place. We're going to be going there.
How far is it
>> in about 20 minutes
>> bro? Do you know do you know what
happened in salah? I didn't heard the
first done. Yeah. I'm standing there
waiting when you said Allah going to cuz
you know got the eye condition. I can't
see properly. So I thought you went into
not I'm doing and 5 seconds later you're
like I'm like bro this guy's the fastest
of my life.
>> Bombastic side eye. Criminal offensive
side eye.
>> I didn't say
>> and then I had to I had to repeat it. It
was caught on camera.
>> I'm doing this.
And then he goes and I'm like, bro, that
that was fast. And it I was like, yo,
this one's romantic, bro. Not knowing.
And I realized, oh snap, I missed the
whole thing. I'll do an extra um an
extra.
>> What the hell is this? We have seen the
evidence.
>> Wait, we got shorts for the ice cuz I'm
going to go in with this. I've got Yeah.
Going like that. Norally,
>> let me just tell you guys a bit about my
lifestyle. Giant's going to get excited
as you can see.
So basically I used to do jogging every
day for the past 5 6 years. Yeah. It
just got so boring. My life's just
boring. Yeah. So this brother said to
me, "Listen, you want to burn more
calories?" I said, "Yeah." He said, "Do
the circuit." So what's the circuit? You
will see it show comprising.
Yeah. 30 second. 30 second. 30 second.
30 second push pull. Push. But that's
light. This is D. Where's the 10 kilos?
You threw it.
>> Yeah.
I was doing so well with the 10. Where's
the 15? Honestly, look guys, usually I
do 10. Now we have to do 15 cuz you see
our strength for this. We couldn't
handle it.
>> Ooh,
>> you're hard showing off cuz you know I
>> That's what I was saying on the way.
That's calisthenics in this
calisthenics.
>> We do this 30 second on the rolling
machine, 30 second on the bike, 30
second on the ski. We push pull on the
sled. Yes. Then we do 10 medicine slam.
And then we do you choose a rep on your
pull-ups, choose a rep on your dips,
choose a rep on your chin-ups, choose a
rep on your push-ups.
>> Okay,
>> that's one round. We see in three to
five rounds. That's that's
>> it. That's calisthenics and conditions.
>> Yeah. 30 30.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay.
Oh,
>> he's
got the shoes.
This is the first set.
I'm trying to tie it to my
>> Yeah.
Leave it. Leave it. That's it. Rest now.
Rest two minutes.
Second round.
>> I haven't done in 2 years.
>> We're at calisthenics gym. what you have
to do kind of thing.
Look at these things are normal.
>> As men, we really need to make peace
with pain. Today we see sadly a lot of
men like couch potatoes. If you ask any
of these brothers here, you guys enjoy
training.
>> I love it.
>> He loves it. Loves he's falling in love
with it. I haven't fallen in love with
it yet. But the point is this guy is
painful. You have to for the mind, the
body, and the soul. Especially men, I
don't enjoy it, bro. I hate it. I hate
the training. I hate the body work. I
hate boxing. I hate the ice bar. But let
me tell you something. I'll pick my
hardships. Either I'm going to have
hardship with Shayan and what's what's
out in the in my house alone. I start
thinking things in my head, make
problems that don't exist. But I'm going
to come here and avoid Shayan. A busy
mindan. We have time for have time for
Shayan.
>> We will be doing that. Look.
>> Yeah. Look, look at this guy. But when
Shayan sees him, he go turns all the way
around. See that pull out with this guy?
I was I was going to say three rounds of
this and then we finish with a burpees
set.
>> Okay.
>> No problem. So, should we finish? Let's
finish. Three rounds.
>> We're done. Three rounds. Done.
>> Do a burp.
>> Okay. 100 burpees.
>> Oh, 100 burpees.
>> Most men are scared of burpees. That's
why to test. You're a real man. You have
to put your f and then do burpees.
>> Burpees.
Lasagna. Chicken chicken burger. That's
why that's what keeps pushing.
>> That's why we train harder though.
>> That's what I was saying. We used to get
one off, bro. Put that back on.
>> Yeah, you train harder. You eat well,
you train harder.
>> Yeah, that's more
ready for it. We're going to go now have
some Turkish kebab.
>> Wait, you still got 100 burpees though.
>> Why do you have to get technical?
Anyways, what's happening with his
straight burpees? That's what he said.
>> Yo,
burpees, man.
>> Look at the excitement.
>> N I hate burpees. That's one thing I
hate. Yeah.
>> No one likes movies.
>> No. Listen. What's the minimum?
>> Told you.
>> I wanted him to say that cuz I know what
he's going to say.
>> Yeah. I'm happy that he said that. I'm
I'm so over the moon.
>> Okay.
>> It's not just normal. It's a different
type of
excited now.
>> I don't know.
>> Hey, what is it?
>> Yeah. So, we're going to do like this.
You're going to do this cuz you're going
to do this. You're going to just be like
this. Just be like THIS AND THEN DO
>> ME.
It might take a bit long, but we're
going to do it.
>> I was saying. Okay.
First you 3 2 1
>> Let's go. Easy.
Yeah.
Punch. Push up. Push up. Touch. Push up.
Touch. Push up.
>> I think the camera angle might need to
change.
We should come this side
the prophet of Allah in the authentic
SPEAKING TO SAHABAH SPEAKING TO THE
GREATEST UMAH THAT EVER WALKED THE EARTH
TODAY YOU DO NOTHING AND YOU THINK
YOU'RE UP THERE THEY DID EVERYTHING AND
THEY THOUGHT THAT THEY WERE DOWN THERE
HE SAYS NONE OF you who's he speaking to
he says none of you will enter ja
through your actions none I asked a
prophet of Allah even you he says yeah
even me THE GREATEST CREATION THAT ALLAH
EVER CREATED WAS MUHAMMAD SAM.
And he says even me except and only if
Allahel wants to show mercy upon me,
bro. Hey, what's the point? What's the
point looking like this if you can't be
on your birthday?
>> That's what I'm saying.
>> That's it. The thing is covered.
>> Depends who you ask.
>> Cuz now you got Dro in the building cuz
you see these brothers always pick on
sisters. Look, look at these guys.
>> But the covered. Yeah.
I stick on them as well.
>> Bear in mind, it's about 35% easier for
me cuz I can't do the press up. So these
guys are smashing it cuz of the things
in
Ali. You love to do it, but it's called
it's birthday shorties. Yeah,
>> shorty mean something else.
Sorry.
>> One.
Last one.
>> Oh, here in MBG muscle basing gym. Left
got the champ and my right got the
champ. The reason I'm topless is cuz I
put them to shape. outside. The real
story is my wife will hit me under here
with brothers trained so bad. But I talk
about blisters
under birth is getting blisters. The
first question is this. Listen, you see
there's a lot of brothers that pick on
sisters the hijab in this time. You guys
wear alhamdulillah sisters know your
gays. This is all alhamdulillah. But
it's been fantastic job brothers out
there. Alhamdulillah trained the mind,
the body and the soul. It is a place
where alhamdulillah we come and sub
there's no half naked girls walking
around. What we hear is the Quran or the
we pray salah together we train together
the mind body and soul for the mind it's
the ice semi location send forget 100
burpees done
>> oh 100 burpees by the way
>> when I did half cuz I got a little
injury
>> health is your
>> I don't know how these mans
bless and preserve us and reunite in
general
you want small
>> you know we're sweating I don't think
these ms
>> no I know but the mats kind of praying
without M cuz I'm sweating. Someone else
going to pray on him while sweats on
him.
>> You You convince me. Now I'm going to
make sure I sweat more. The M value
rolls up. Look, I'm going to be honest
with you guys. You can try train the
body. They can look hench. The brothers
here, alhamdulillah, look fantastic
physically. But to me, anyone that
doesn't pray salah and look strong is a
weak person. I genuinely believe this.
Abdull, if I'm not mistaken, he was once
climbing the tree and some of the
Sahabas saw him and he used to have
skinny legs. I'm going to get in this
>> and the Sahabah started laughing at him.
He said look at his skinny legs
>> and the prophetam came and said wall in
the sight of Allah his legs are heavier
than mhood. So we sometimes look at the
external but it's it's a salah your
connection with Allah that makes you
strong or weak.
We've trained the body. We've trained
the soul. We're going to train the mind
and that's the heat room and the ice. So
I'm going to go in there for 10 minutes
with the brother and I'm going to jump
into the ice. See you guys later.
>> 2,000 years later.
>> Fast. I'm fast.
Ice bath now. Can you keep 1 and 1/2
minute time off? This is 6°. Your shower
in your house is 15° that you scream
about. Cold. Yeah.
Woo.
light work
>> center this time and forget they did
this for breakfast. So what I usually do
is control my breathing first and then
afterwards for time to go I usually
recite the Quran and I'll just stand
tires but what am I supposed to do?
Simply a mix. Yeah, rough riders. No.
How long left?
>> One whole minute.
>> What?
>> 1 minute.
>> Usually I keep my hands out cuz the
hands are really painful. So yeah, but
this is good. This is more for the mind
to regulate pain. The part of the brain
for pain and pleasure is the same place.
So don't confuse this as like a body.
This is a mind issue. You're right now
focusing. This is pain. This is pain.
This I hate this. I hate every second of
this. But let me tell you something.
I'll pick my hardships. Either I'm going
to spend time with Shayan in the home.
Give me stuff in my head that doesn't
even exist and make my problems bigger
than it really is. I'm going to be here,
bro. And I'm going to deal with this.
This is easier. That's what Allah says
in the Quran.
With hardship comes ease. Very with
hardship comes ease. I'll go through the
hardship now with this straight time at
home. Bro, cuz he put all kind of stuff
in my head.
>> 10 seconds.
>> So light work.
I'm just talking. This is this mental.
This is mental. This is mental. This is
pain.
Three, two,
>> one.
>> Forgot to press record.
No,
>> joking.
Welcome to my crib, guys. Yeah.
Believe me, I'm telling you, even when
it comes to respect from your wife,
right? Everyone deals with something.
You know, wives get emotional says get
the best of us. Wives gave a hard time.
You make a wish Allah subhana wa tala
and that your wife notices that. That's
why, you know, I agree with some people
when they come and say, "Well, I don't
wake up to make my wife happy. I don't
wake up and say, yo, listen, I'm going
to make my wife happy. That's not my
mission. That's not my goal. I don't say
how I'm going to make my kids happy.
That's not my mission or my goal. My mom
and dad happy. Of course, I want to, but
that's not my mission and goal. My
mission and goal is how can I make the
one who created me happy? When my focus
is there, of course, those things
follow. Wives, children, family members,
mom and dad. But the main vision and the
focus has to be Allah subhana wa tala in
everything we do. When a woman looks at
this guy on his mission, bro, he's got a
focus. Whatever it is, Allah has to be
there. If you're an engineer, Allah has
to be there. If you're a biologist,
Allah has to be there. Whatever. If
you're a doctor, Allah has to be there.
The same with the sisters. Whatever you
do, your main focus and goal is it Allah
only to waste of time. When you die,
Allah has finished. Make your focus and
mission Allah and Allah will put all
your efforts in this. If you don't and
make your mission go and this and that
really because anything
that you jump back to jump back into
another second time it gets more
painful. Yeah, it gets more painful. One
hand is done for the day. You know what
I'm going to do now? You're not
finished. I'm going to go and sleep. YOU
WANT YOU s
do something. You know why? Cuz now is
to help other people save their souls.
All of not for us. Can't be selfish,
bro. Prophet said, "Not for your brother
this way, not for yourself." What I'm
going to go do now is
Who has a shower with his clothes?
10 to 10.
>> Listen, today I was on a mat. Listen, I
showed you guys what I do every day and
you guys are not ready for that. Get me.
I pulled a bicep muscle. Ah, today was a
mad day. We got some guests from
Bradford. They came here. Alhamdulillah.
I done a podcast to Bros podcast and
let's play a game. Brand new shows
coming forward. Inshallah.
Alhamdulillah. We train together. We
filmed together. Alhamdulillah. The
mind, body, and soul. And then I went in
the ice bath. I went in the ice bath.
Haki. I had I was I was on a matic. So,
alhamdulillah. We did that. And now
we're at the DA table. The brothers are
going to Letto tell them to go eat some
cake with me. They're going to bring me
the Sebastian cheesecake. You're having
none. Okay, don't even try it. My day
usually starts fudger. Get the a have to
do. Wake up at 10:30. Do 30 minutes of
Quran. Go to the gym usually, but today
the filming was done. We went to gym a
bit late. Listen, Salah pro. Are you
mad, bro? Man's man's on point. I'm too
legit to quit. He missed the action.
It's not ready for it. My skin came off
my toes. My big toes skin came off, bro.
Cuz man 100 burpees. My defense
impregnable. I'm Alexander. I'm
Alexander. I'm I'm I'm Let's go. It was
a good day.